Once we chain all these functions together,
according to this pipeline the web browser takes this specification and renders
a web page filled with all the graphics that we've specified across the chain.
At its most fundamental level, the Grammar of Graphics makes
the distinction to separate content or data from the aesthetic.
In this case, the web page we're visualizing.
This may not seem like a ground breaking theory, but before the Grammar of
Graphics, researchers, artists, and developers often coupled the information
they were trying to communicate with the medium of communication.
That is all I want to touch on the Grammar of Graphics for now.
But I encourage all of you to look at the extra resources provided if
you either want to dive deeper to what some of these specifications of
the Grammar of Graphics mean, or the d3 functions that correspond to them.
We will re-visit this concept of separating data from presentation throughout
the course, and is one of the most powerful design decisions of the d3 library.